[Música]
eeuu enviará un paquete de armas a
ucrania por el valor de 150 millones de
dólares con esta decisión de la casa
blanca washington ya ha dedicado
suministros por más de 3400 millones de
dólares para respaldar a kiev en la
guerra
más de dos decenas de personas murieron
en la explosión del hotel saratoga en
cuba el presidente miguel díaz canel
visitó el lugar después del siniestro y
desde allí enfatizó que fue un
lamentable accidente y no un atentado
el mandatario mexicano andrés manuel
lópez obrador continúa su gira regional
el viernes viajó a el salvador y
honduras y al igual que ocurrió en
guatemala el tema central del encuentro
del presidente con sus homólogos fue la
migración
bienvenidos a las noticias de france 24
mi nombre es maría clara calle y es un
placer acompañarlos y comenzamos en eeuu
el presidente joe biden firmó un nuevo
paquete de 150 millones de dólares para
enviar misiles municiones radares y
otros equipos a ucrania la casa blanca
puede retirar armas y material de las
fuerzas militares estadounidenses para
dárselo a otras naciones en una
situación de emergencia y desde allí
desde donde vendrán esos recursos desde
que empezó la guerra nuclear ya de eeuu
le ha brindado armamento a kiev por un
valor de 3.400 millones de dólares
adicionalmente el congreso estudia un
proyecto que si es aprobado le proveería
asistencia por más de 33 mil millones de
dólares a los ucranianos
y nos vamos a ucrania los paramédicos en
esta guerra son los primeros en llegar
tras un ataque y desde que empezó la
invasión rusa al menos un tercio del
personal clínico ha abandonado la ciudad
de kharkiv la segunda más importante del
país quienes se quedan trabajan ahora
bajo el silbido de los misiles nuestras
enviadas especiales irene sabio y
leticia álvarez nos acompañaron en una
de sus jornadas y esto fue lo que vieron
se encargan de atender a las víctimas de
bombardeos cuando un misil impacta en su
distrito tienen segundos para salir
corriendo a ayudar juliá tiene 27 años y
está al mando ella decide cada
movimiento
si el miembro de alto rango es quien
toma la decisión si una ambulancia va a
un ataque grande y se necesitan más
coches es el primero en llegar el que se
queda hasta el final hasta el último
paciente tenemos una clasificación de
pacientes así que vemos quién necesita
ayuda urgente y el primer equipo hace
primeros auxilios y llama a otros coches
chad en un ambiente hostil como éste es
fundamental trabajar en equipo en
aquellas demora fue tve es un asco a
yulia desde hace mucho tiempo y por fin
trabajamos juntos para mí esta es mi
pequeña segunda familia
es inevitable preguntarles por el miedo
a un segundo bombardeo que hiciera que
ellos los primeros en llegar al lugar
también sean alcanzados por la metralla
todo el miedo se queda en un segundo
plano porque entendemos que alguien
necesita más ayuda nosotros estamos bien
cuando oyes explosiones encima de tu
cabeza tienes miedo un segundo pero
luego mantienes el control y sigues
trabajando gato caótico extra perleta no
son las 12 de la mañana y mientras
esperamos
varios misiles sobrevuela en la central
de paramédicos y acabamos de recibir una
alerta y han disparado contra un parque
uno de los parques más importantes aquí
en
en menos de 10 minutos llegamos al
parque
[Música]
de fondo retumba la artillería esta
mujer ha resultado herida después de que
un misil impactara cuando paseaba con
sus dos hijos y su marido tiene dañados
los pulmones
los paramédicos se juegan la vida a
diario en esta guerra de ucrania yulia
valeri y eugeni vuelven al centro de
mando y repasan las alertas todavía les
quedan horas de trabajo por delante y
están en la primera línea del fuego
hungría rechazó la propuesta de la
comisión europea de embargar las
importaciones de petróleo ruso el primer
ministro viktor orbán señaló que frenar
esas compras equivaldría a una bomba
atómica para la economía húngara según
sus cálculos del país necesitaría al
menos cinco años para dejar de depender
del petróleo ruso
es un paso demasiado lejos para viktor
orbán el viernes el primer ministro
húngaro rechazó el último proyecto de
sanciones a las exportaciones de
petróleo ruso anunciado por la unión
europea bouton estábamos dispuestos a
decir que si a los primeros cinco
paquetes de sanciones pero desde la
primera oportunidad dejamos claro que
habrá una línea roja de no ir tan lejos
y que no podamos estar de acuerdo con
ellos esto se trata de un embargo
energético
esta propuesta es como una bomba nuclear
lanzada sobre la economía húngara
los funcionarios de la unión europea
habían previsto una excepción para
hungría y eslovaquia dos países
dependientes del gas ruso y que podrían
haber continuado con su compra de
petróleo ruso hasta finales del 2023
pero orbán afirma que necesitan más
tiempo y
sabemos exactamente lo que necesitamos y
necesitamos cinco años para completar
todo el proceso no llegaremos a ninguna
parte con una exención de un año y medio
un rechazo que fue inmediatamente
criticado por ucrania
distraerse nicandro in europe google en
youtube post
si algún país de europa sigue
oponiéndose a un embargo del petróleo
ruso reservación sin embargo con ryan
webb
habrá buenas razones para decir que ese
país es cómplice de los crímenes
cometidos por rusia en territorio
ucraniano
barbassa in the tree of y break las
sanciones de la unión europea contra
rusia no pueden entrar en vigor sin el
acuerdo de los 27 estados miembros
en noticias de américa más de 20
personas murieron por la explosión en el
hotel saratoga en la habana según los
cálculos de la presidencia cubana las
autoridades buscan cuál fue la causa de
la detonación y su hipótesis preliminar
es que pudo haber sido un escape de gas
una explosión en el hotel saratoga de la
habana uno de los más emblemáticos y
lujosos sacudió la isla al lugar de los
hechos acudieron las autoridades donde
el presidente cubano descartó que se
tratara de alguna amenaza nunca asociado
una bomba ni ha sido un atentado a los
medios internacionales de manera muy
perverso
el accidente se habría originado debido
a una fuga de gas en el hotel que
permanecía cerrado por más de dos años
debido a la pandemia de kobe 19 y que se
esperaba para su reapertura el 10 de
mayo hasta ahora no hay
[Música]
información de que existan bien
extranjero
muy fácil pero bueno la información es
muy primaria el estallido en el lujoso
hotel ubicado en el centro histórico se
produjo sobre las 10 50 de la mañana
provocando el derrumbe de varios pisos
del edificio y un incendio varias
personas han quedado atrapadas bajo los
escombros mientras los familiares
esperan angustiados
el presidente cubano miguel díaz canel
informó que se iniciará una
investigación para aclarar las causas de
lo sucedido en un mismo día el
presidente mexicano andrés manuel lópez
obrador se reunió en san salvador con el
mandatario bukele y luego viajó a
tegucigalpa para reunirse con su
homóloga hondureña xiomara castró amplio
irá del sábado a belice y terminará sus
viajes en cuba el domingo en la gira
regional
lópez obrador promueve dos políticas
para atacar la migración de raíz en un
intento por fortalecer las alianzas
mexicanas con el triángulo norte de
centroamérica escuchamos lo que dijeron
al respecto castro y lópez obrador
[Aplausos]
la migración
es el resultado
de las difíciles condiciones que viven
nuestros países del río grande hacia el
sur
juntos lucharemos contra la violencia
que nos acechan
defendiendo los derechos de los
migrantes
esta clase de migración
obligatoria se lo ha señalado y masiva
es un fenómeno que involucra a los
países de origen
a los de tránsito ya los de llegada
y la única forma de resolverlo es
mediante el entendimiento y la
cooperación multilateral
por eso en mexico mi gobierno está
empeñado
en un proyecto de desarrollo y
generación de bienestar
para arraigar a la tierra a quienes hoy
no tienen otro remedio que abandonarla
la inseguridad de la capital de haití es
tanta que decenas de personas salieron a
las calles de puerto príncipe a
protestar en los barrios del norte de la
ciudad y es que allí en la zona conocida
como la llanura de culdesac han matado a
por lo menos 75 civiles en las dos
últimas semanas según la onu los
enfrentamientos entre 400 magos y chen
me echan por controlar el territorio ha
provocado el desplazamiento de cientos
de familias
hasta aquí las noticias sigan con
nosotros
[Música]